good afternoon everyone and welcome to
the um planning and Regulatory meeting
for
November are there any apologies I have
one from councelor Andy Fraser and I
think that is the only person missing
can I have a mover in a second um please
um for that thank you councelor Stringer
seconded by councilor McDonald all those
in favor say I Against carried are there
any conflicts of interest in terms of
what's on the agenda
today there appears to be not we have a
short agenda today that has three items
on it dealing with the planning update
Heritage buildings and the um a report
on the C management policy for the
council the way I'm intending to handle
the meeting today is each of the items
is relatively short um but we need to be
in a position to actually have a bit of
a uh discussion outside of the formal
type Council um committee meeting uh so
what I'm proposing to do is that with
the report on the C management policy we
will have questions of the staff and
then close the meeting and we will then
have a workshop to go through the
options in terms of what will be dealt
with um potentially in that policy and
that will be open to the public and
everyone who is here is able to stay the
prime reason for doing it is that we're
able to then have a more General
chitchat um and uh outside of the normal
standing orders the other option is to
just suspend standing orders but I think
it's easier um if we deal with it in in
that format it also provides um a few
lessons to learn on the way that we deal
with um open workshops moving forward so
there any questions from counselors or
staff in that
regard appears to be not the first item
on the agenda is a uh planning update um
from our Consultants that sets out the
number of consents are there any
questions arising from that
please while you're having a thought I
have to Katrina the last um bulletin
that came out a couple of days ago
showed us a bit of a decline and the
number of building consents we're
getting yes um which and um there
appears to also be a decline in in the
number of resource consents that we're
getting as well is this one month or is
it a trend so I'll be interested to hear
both from Russell and and Katrina in
terms of what's going on out there
because um it's a sign of economic
activity for a couple of months out if
we've got consents reducing um for sure
so in this report I've specified that
there were 12 resource consents lodged
in September and October 10 of those
were September and only two October so
we had very quiet and very unusually
quiet October and um knowing that the
building consens were low as well that
does speak to that there is a bit of a
um slowdown and what's coming in the
door but also from a planning point of
view we know practitioners are busy
putting in submissions on the proposed
District plan and we had a bit of an
increase in consent applications around
July August in advance of the proposed
District plan being notified so it might
be a mixture of things things um but you
will have to just monitor the months
ahead to see whether it's a trend or
just a blip but we are getting inquiries
and pre-application meetings still and
from what we're hearing from industry is
they still do have consents to
Lodge right Russell from your point of
view um from the building point of view
yes in a bulletin that you may have seen
um um 10 days ago when I put it out it
was um pretty much for o October we've
seen probably the lowest um um
application number of building as sense
in for for several years um I think it
was 11 for the whole of October whereas
normally it's averages around 28 to 30
somewhere in that region so yeah I had
comments on that bulletin that I'm not
sure whether it's just a a one-off thing
um or whether it's a postco rush is now
gone or or um whether it's a
financial um sort of holding point for a
lot of people or whether it's a a
preforming of this new government
holding pattern for some people that are
just wondering what's going to progress
so I'm hoping it's only going to be for
that one to two month period um our
normal Christmas rush hasn't happened
yet
so all right thank you for that from
both of you um any other questions from
councellors Katrina there's a number of
consents and progress present one of
them from Kang can you give us an update
on where that's at
please sure so this is a development um
on Hamilton Street the old Heaven site
um for a multi-unit development for
Kanga Aura so we have um issued a
limited notification decision which
means some of the neighbors most of the
adjacent directly adjacent neighbors
have been served notice and um have the
opportunity to make a submission on that
resource consent so that's where it's at
in the process currently is it's open
for submissions to those limited number
of
parties and when do submissions close um
so I'm not sure the exact date off the
top of my head but it's around mid
December um they just opened last week
so there's the 20-day period um which
means should there be submissions in
this progress to hearing we're likely to
have a hearing around February to take
into account the Christmas shut down and
then evidence exchange right thank
you any other comments from
counselors no it was recommended the
report be um received if I can have move
in a second if that please um Joe
Stringer moving councilor Broman Reed
seconding all those in favor say I
against carried item two is Heritage
buildings um arising from a council
meeting recently we asked for a report
to come to this committee um with
provision to wave consent fees um for uh
consents needed where work is done on
Heritage buildings both the building
consents and the resource consent side
of it are there any questions from
councilors
please councilor Reed thank you Mr chair
here um one thing I noticed might be a
question for Russell to answer please um
mainly business properties that we're
talking about as opposed to private
properties sorry question is just that
it's mainly um business properties that
are affected by this yes not residential
yes um
Katrina with with some something else
yes
pleas um so under the operative District
plan it's just business but with the
proposed District plan um it is proposed
to list a number of Residential
Properties as well so going forward um
it would apply to both business and
residential you so further to that my
question would be um are rate payers
going to sub uh subsidize private people
um and
this fee consents being wed
um through you m Mr chairman not really
I think the argument here is that the
community has placed a value on
Heritage uh and has through the through
through it the district plan
process uh and in in doing so has placed
uh restrictions on property owners what
they can and can't do so the argument
put forward is that uh if there is need
for consense to
upgrade uh surely the community should
um pay a contribution to enabling that
upgrading to take place and preserve the
Heritage that Community thinks is
desirable to preserve that that's the
that's the argument so it's I can see
you're arguing about well are people
financing private individual Property
Owners uh I think the private property
owner would say well I didn't ask for
this Heritage classification or
preservation I'm now um obliged to
follow it uh it would be nice for the
community who places this high value on
the preservation that's building to
assist me in upgrading the property
through waving consense not funding the
actual upgrade but just waving consents
so that fees so that um the pathway
forward and and upgrading the property
is less owner would have would have been
if you just said well you're on your own
we've placed a a a Heritage um status on
your property but any extra burden or
cost falls on you not the not the rate
power Community uh that wants this
preserve that's the Cen of the
argument thank you that's a good clear
answer do we have any idea of how many
homes would potentially be Heritage
listed in G or in within the
district
uh 87 on 87 scheduled in the proposed
District plan that could change
depending on submissions received um but
this stage is 87 and that's up from 60 I
think in the current plan and that's
overall buildings not just residential
cor how many
residential half a dozen
30 I'll have to check to give you the
exact number
but it'll be around about 50
residential so what you say in the
reports that you anticipate one a year
and setting aside
$25,000 um a year um for subsidizing the
fees what happens if there are none that
year are you proposing that in fact it
accumulates over several
years uh I would be uh Mr chairman yes
because you might get uh two or three
one year and a couple years of of of
Silence um we need to if you're going to
have this um initiative in place we need
to uh wave the fees and we need to have
the fees that would have been earned
directed to the relevant departments
whether it's resource management or
building from the Grant's budget so my
proposal would be to the ability to
accumulate a reserve for waving consent
fees on a yearby year basis with an
allocation of say 20
$25,000 and um I guess the second part
of that is that the intent is that where
someone is doing something positive to a
Heritage building that that the waiver
would apply except that it wouldn't
apply for a notified
application whereas if they're doing
something positive surely they should be
subsidized still to the same extent why
should the status of an application
dictate whether you give a subsidy or
not
uh Katrina can answer as well but we had
a brief chat about that and thought well
when it comes to notification generally
there is some CommunityWide impact and
it may not uh be seen it could it could
be a controversial project and the
council may want to just um give itself
a tad uh rle room before automatically
offering a consent waiver
now you could have a very controversial
project um or use a business use that
may not be considered to be particularly
appropriate or or wanted uh and it may
still um involve preserving a building
uh I've got one or two ideas in M but
rather not speculate in a public setting
um and that could cause the council some
discomfort but an ability to say
consider a fee waver on its merits when
notified at least gives you that um an
exit
door yeah so publicly notified consense
um to publicly notify consent there has
to be adverse effects that are more than
minor um so it might not be considered
um favorable to subsidize a consent for
somebody when the adverse effects um
more than minor so there's a difference
to the other consents there um and ones
that are generally likely to end up
that's Fe a full Demolition consents and
um essentially the purpose of this is
try to enable people to do you know
adaptive reuse with Heritage buildings
or maybe ads and alss or something to
help preserve the Heritage and so you
kind of lose that in effect if you're
doing a demolition or something that
could really compromise those Heritage
values yeah Council
Stringer through you Mr cheer um so so
we pass what's the chances that we get a
run of people wanting to do or put
consens all of a sudden do we say right
um yours might push out to next year or
next year and the other question would
be is it a grant or should it be under
some other line
item um through Mr cheer on both those
issues um if you got to run on um uh
projects I
in theory you should be pleased because
everyone suddenly embracing Heritage and
preservation wanting to restore their
buildings um bear in mind that the owner
still has to front with the capital cost
uh which is the major part of of the
development um if we got a run I think
we would it's we would just have to
manage it as best we can um it'd be hard
to see based on history that we get more
than two or three a year based on what
I'm talking to with uh the Russ and his
team um and historically when it comes
to waving fees It generally comes out of
a grants budget it's considered to be a
a council Grant uh to um and in good
faith and what we've always done is make
sure that rather than just say don't
have to worry about the money just
disappears um the building and the
resource management departments are um
80 to 90% user pace so therefore what we
do is if we offer a fee waiver that the
money to um uh facilitate that comes out
of Grants and then the actual that means
that the resource management and
building control section still get the
fee but it's paid for by the general
rate PA via grants as opposed to the
user that
explains listening to the replies and in
terms of um notified
consents um I'm wondering how and and
also it applies to change of use so if
there's a change of use to a building
Russell how how would that result
potentially in a positive outcome in
terms of preserving the building what
what sort of
circumstances would would generate that
I can understand it for a resource
consent um wanting to improve but how
would it work for a building consent
wanting to improve yep through you Mr
chair um depending on what the what the
building was and what the new use was
going to be um because obviously
generally the way to get a a change of
use approved through the building Act is
by lodging a building consent
application and that is generally to say
change uh for example an upstairs
storage area of a commercial building
into a um apartment for example and that
is a change of use under the building
act because you you're going from a from
a less onerous um use into a more
onerous use where there's going to be
residential accommodation so that is
covered under any building consent for
that change of use and by that that also
may affect their rating components that
they pay for for that premise um so that
is all Incorporated normally and a
building canc an application so that's
only relating to the internal part of
the
building yes if that's all they're doing
right so so back to Katrina how many of
our heritage buildings that are listed
relate to the internal parts of the
building my understanding is it only
applies to the external
Parts correct with Razor's consents
concerned about the
external so so should should this
provision therefore apply to the
building consent side of it or only the
resource consent because what's in now
plan is only protection of the external
parts of building not the
internals some feedback from
counselors blank
faces so in case the the the it wasn't
understood so the the report that we've
got says that we should be waving fees
when there's a positive impact on
Heritage buildings and people wanting to
do things but the only Pro C that would
go through from what Russell's just
described as a resource consent to make
external changes not a building consent
to make external changes therefore
should the policy apply to building
consents have I got that right Russell
it would depend if it was a structural
change right structural change of any or
earthquake strengthening anything like
that it automatically triggers a
building consent and that may affect the
overall um look or the Integrity of of
the outer structure which may be
protected so does does a structural
change flow from a change of use under
the building act um it can be in tandem
to that it doesn't necessarily align
with it well yeah so a good example is
the east and south and art gallery and
its
strengthening um that so so that was a a
building project on a Heritage structure
and it was strengthen for seism
resistance to preserve its useful life
um and would have required a building
consent not a change of use but a
building consent and you you will get I
think a number of those I think the
majority will be in that in that area
and the minority will be in the change
of business use where someone wants to
say I've got to start church and I want
to create a residence for example or a
business within that
church um I might just add because
sometimes the resource consents are
bundled so the Heritage rules are about
external but if they are doing a change
of use like a commercial activity in a
residential Zone you might have other
consent triggers bundled in with it okay
right so we've got um at the bottom of
page five um a series of recommendations
that be received the 25,000 be set aside
now I've got a question coming from Joe
thank you three Mr chair um potentially
how many buildings would this help on
the Main Street of they want to go
through the process of earthquake
strengthening and stuff like
that we need to through you Mr chair we
need to look at the schedule in the
proposed District plan they're all
scheduled and
um I have the schedule but I have to um
manually count them up so
I'll have a look but um the current 30
under the operative plan most of them
are CBDs my
understanding councelor Dixon thank you
Mr chair um just wondering because most
of the buildings that do our heritage
buildings that do have change they just
change the facade which is the front of
the building so if we're going to
compensate for consent would that be
consent for the whole building or just
the part that they're
offering um through you Mr chairman very
good question um we would my report has
been predicated on the basis that the
whole job would be fee wavered so I
talked in my report about well I think I
certainly um I used a $1 million
commercial upgrade as a an example of a
project and the fee would be $11,000 so
I guess what I'm saying in that report
is that we would have the whole job
which would be the facade and internal
would attract a fee waiver thinking that
it's very hard to kind of separate them
and ultimately you want an
attractive um building that is preserve
for future use as as your policy
objective
may be
Bell thank you Mr chair I think it's a
um a good move and i' I'd be in
supportive at um listening to our
community and and understanding that
there are a lot of uh buildings Heritage
buildings that do need earthquake
strengthening so um while as the chief
executive pointed out um in his report
um that they are million dollars
upgrades and $11,000 as drop in the
bucket for those upgrades um any
incentive I think to try and get those
buildings up to scratch as as is a good
thing I just as you were getting into
the recommendations I was just wondering
whether we can make a slight change um
procedurally um given that it's coming
out of the grants budget and I know
there's quite a bit of work going on um
in the grants committee around what is a
grant and what isn't um whether it's
best that that be changed to uh that
that uh that the committee asked uh the
grants committee to set aside the sum of
5,000 I just feel like it should be
incorporated as part of the overall
Grant
conversation um rather than it going
directly to counil um more of a
procedural thing than
a so just so we can look at all of the
grants together um when it comes
time procedurally is there an
issue Mr chairman no not law as purely
the committee's discretion um
and you have a grant subcommittee that's
uh geared up for this task so why
not councilor Reed further to that do we
actually need to note that if that fund
is not required in a particular year
that it becomes
um cumulative yes that was the word I
did have written down thank
you if so I'm happy to move the motion
or the recommendation okay well there's
um four of them there um but first um
n thank you Mr chair um Al know not a
member of this committee I am the
chairman of the grants committee and it
would have been my wish that we'
probably have that money set aside to
the GRS committee so we can make a
decision or when it becomes NMU or a
gred such to the thing to to make that
decision on that on that aspect
thanks so there's two suggestions for
change uh in terms of what MIA Bell has
suggested that go to the grants
committee uh it is probably best then
that um we look at them um one at a time
um and we'll play around with the
wording as we go so can uh we have a mov
that the report be received please uh
councelor Stringer second Council
McDonald all those in favor say I
against carried mayor Bell H do you wish
therefore to word the second
recommendation uh that the
committee uh requests that the grant
committee the grant subcommittee set
aside the sum of Da so it'll just read
that that the grants sub Grant
subcommittee set aside yeah that's
perfect instead of council yeah uh any
other changes require um to that yes
there are in terms of what council Reed
said so by adding the words at the end
uh change of use of the building concern
and uh that sum be available
cumulatively if um unused in any
year or or not yeah yes or if any
unexpended money's be transferred over
to successive years
right so um I guess m Bell you'd want to
move that
and you would like I I think Council
Reed moved it I'm happy to Second it
though right yes thank you all those in
favor say I against carried the third
recommendation that the resource consent
fees for a change of business only be
waved with the applications non-notified
or limited notified and I just want to
flag I'm going to introduce another one
immediately after this uh in relation to
notified consent so uh can I have a move
in a second that recommendation as
worded please councelor mcdal and
secondly councelor Dixon all those in
favor sayi against carried I'd like to
add another recommendation and there on
move another one and that the
council uh has a
discretion as to whether resource
consent fees for a
change yes for a change of business use
only uh
have a discretion where the application
is
notified you're preserving your position
yes yes rather than saying no it's not
going to be um so any any comments
coming back from
that so I moved it can I have a second
so that we have a discretion then uh
thank you councelor Reed uh comment uh
just to question what um I guess what
would the threshold be then for that
discretion uh it's in terms of the uh
what I think the chief executive
described as the desirability of the use
um or or the extent of work that's
required so it just gives uh
consideration and um my note at the end
of this is do we need an operational
policy to actually Implement all these
recommendations and I think your
question is is is spot on in terms of
that so I think we had a move on a
second um for that um did I ask of all
in
favor I yes against carried thank you no
dissenting views and the um next
recommendation
um that no reduction uh in the the
building of resource consent fees be
offered where the owner wishes to
demolish the Heritage structure can have
a move for that please thank you
councilor McKenzie second Council
McDonald all those in favor say I
against carried I think the fine is now
one packet of chocolate
biscuits and finally that um that the
proposed consent fee waiver for Heritage
structures being included in the draft
long-term plan for Community feedback
thank you move counselor uh Dixon
seconded by Mia bell all those in favor
say I against carried thank you um I'll
just have a
drink item three progress report on cap
management policy for the G District so
we have a six page or so report that's
um come from
Morgan um that the flags a number of
issues and um gives some thoughts on
what's Happening overseas can I have any
questions sorry Mr chair sorry to
interrupt um were you going to add a
further recommendation the past one yes
thank you before we move on appreciate
and um so a further
recommendation um is really I need to
ask the question first I guess of the
chief executive given we've passed all
those is there some benefit in the
council having a policy that actually
looks at the implementation of
that of of these different um I think Mr
chairman you'll find that there's um
plans a foot to have other matters
relative to Heritage and providing
incentives coming before the council I
think I think that can be wrapped up in
an overall policy depending on where the
council lands on that um for example
there are you know there are um such
things as potential rating incentives as
well that the council may consider now
that's going to be in a paper that um we
intend to bring up in the new year for
New Year and that might the time when
you've landed on your different policy
settings that you put in place an
overall
policy rather than having just conceded
fees on hero to standing loan all right
so it'll be noted in the minutes could
be picked up later are you comfortable
with that does it need to be a
recommendation that these are
incorporated into a larger policy just
so that it is so it's actioned yeah yeah
yeah so if you'd like to move that thank
you can I have a second please uh
councelor Stringer all those in favor I
against carried just one clarification
for the minutes Mr J and um would it be
fair to say that uh that this be
included in a Heritage in
policy yes yes
so I think that's good progress on on
that issue thank you so the k um report
do we have any questions arising in
terms of what's in the report please and
then we'll have a little bit of a
discussion and then close the meeting
and and work through a number of issues
in terms of where we should
sit uh
cleus thank thank you Mr chair I just I
just have one question we've gotten here
that there's three different categories
of
cats the feral domestic and stray cats
but I note that the national policy
statement on cats has got five different
classes of cats and some are um the
Stray Cats is socialized stray cats or
unsocialized stray cats so are we just
ask Moran that question are
we categorizing those cats as well or
just having the
three areas for you Mr chair thank you
councelor Dixon um I suppose on the face
of it those
differentiations uh like socialized
Strays or something like this could fall
under the wider umbrella of say a stray
c um but of course going forward
incorporating those
sub differentiations into C management
policy wouldn't be too much doing so um
it depends on what the policy regulation
committee lands on with respect to
that thank
you any other
questions I have a question for our
parks and reserves manager in terms of
what action does the council currently
take
as part of its Pest Management strategy
on Council Reserve Land and other
Council
land through through you Mr chair um we
don't actually have a policy on cats so
um our um we we have a external
contractor who does um piss control and
cats are not um and his list of um
targets are they a
um an accidental catch in
sometimes yeah as discussed um they
don't have a record of cats okay yeah
all
right any other questions of staff from
counselors uh councelor
McKenzie just really a comment um we
need to keep it as simple as possible if
we have all these different grades of
cats how do you decide which is which it
makes it very complicated for whoever is
making that decision I just want to make
the comment it needs to be kept as
simple as possible yeah I'm sure the
staff would highlight that um the
difference between a feral cat and a a
Home Companion type cat is very obvious
but the ones in between are more
difficult absolutely so Simplicity we
here thank
yeah okay any other
questions so we have a recommendation
that the report be
received can I have a mover for that
please councelor Dixon McDonald second
uh all those in favor say I I against
carried I will now formally close the
meeting and now open a uh Workshop shop
setting in terms of discussing some of
the issues and where our policy level um
could potentially lie and and for the
benefits of the press we're having an
open discussion here of things that we
would like staff to consider options
that might be available and anything
said in the following um session that we
have does not reflect Council policy nor
should it reflect the views of any
person who makes that we are sharing
ideas for the sake of
discussion the purpose of of of the next
little bit really flows from the council
meeting that we had previously where the
council resolved that we shouldn't have
a separate bylaw that's dealing with
desexing microchipping or
registration um uh but we should be
preparing a policy whenever councils
prepare a
policy um the first thing we usually do
is have a look at what other councils
have done
in this case no other Council that I'm
aware of and um Morgan's not aware of
actually has a policy on cats there's a
number of councils that have bylaws that
that have rules in them relating to cats
there's a number of councils that have a
lot of material on their website um in
terms of giving education and
information um about cats and what good
behavior um should be so we're we're
starting from first principles in terms
terms of the way we deal with it and so
really the first question that that we
just need to have a quick chat about is
what are we actually wanting to achieve
with a policy what's our
objective
Robert it's now informal yeah I I get
that um I'm going to say again keep it
simple I don't think the council's got
enough money to be building buildings
for cats and that sort sort of thing I
think we need to encourage
microchipping I think we need to
encourage getting them
fixed that's the two main things and how
you get that out there if there was
funding available from other sources to
help with the um getting them youth not
euthanized to getting them um uses or
whatever if there was funding available
somewhere for that and having some way
of encouraging people to look after
those animals and not have them roaming
around all over the place breeding do
you mind if I used the Whiteboard and
put a few things up there you've used a
couple of them for no we're having a
bladeb conversation and I'm all for
keeping it simple but not spending a
whole lot of money on
them hope
these so you talked about
encouragement
funing sources
y that's almost an implementation level
but from an overview level what what is
it that we want to
achieve stats around
to the ideas of something I did I think
that we don't want to see any more feral
cats or unsocialized stray cats in our
town I think we have to be quite careful
about cat numbers the um numbers of cats
that people can have at their households
because there are a lot of people who
are now um picking up stray cats and
they've got them at home in fact I've
spoken to